monsieur le ministre depuis 140 ans
belfort forge une des plus belles
aventures industriel de notre pays en ce
qui concerne notamment les centrales
nucléaires et le tgv ce savoir faire est
aujourd'hui gravement menacée par la
situation du site de general electric à
belfort lors du rachat de la branche
énergie d'alstom le projet de jj soutenu
par le gouvernement prévoyait la
création de 1000 emplois nets en france
le ministre de l'économie et des
finances de l'époque l'actuel président
de la république était d'ailleurs venu à
belfort nous expliquer que et je le cite
belfort à un avenir industriel
cet avenir industriel fait partie
d'abord des engagements pris de part et
d'autre et ses engagements sont suivis
par le gouvernement depuis c'est la
suppression de 2 164 postes
la non création de 1000 emplois promis
et c'est près de 1000 postes de
l'activité gaz qui serait aujourd'hui
menacé
l'annnonce de ce plan social aurait été
opportunément repoussé pour ne pas
intervenir avant les élections
européennes
si c'est le cas l'économie du territoire
de belfort et les salariés de general
electric mérite mieux que des
arrangements politiques et seul le
gouvernement dispose des clés pour
amorcer le redressement de l'industrie
belfortaine monsieur le ministre les
possibilités de diversification existent
elles vous ont été soumises par un
certain nombre d'élus du départ et du
territoire de belfort
c'est notamment le programme d'edf pour
augmenter la durée de vie du parc
nucléaire dont les turbines vapeur sont
fabriqués à belfort c'est aussi les
marchés tréport le marché très porteur
des moteurs d'avion porté par safran et
general electric aviation s'est encore
l'implantation de l'institut national de
stockage de l'hydrogène ou l'appel à
projets territoire d'innovation
alors monsieur le ministre quelle
orientation le gouvernement retient-il
pour amorcer ce redressement urgent pour
le territoire de belfort
merci pour vous répondre la parole et
que la secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'économie et des finances
en allemagne espagne et ronald schild
ailleurs parole monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur perrin comme vous
le savez
10 alstom à toute l'attention du
gouvernement et ce depuis de nombreuses
années le 7 février dernier bruno le
maire et moi-même réunissions le comité
de suivi des engagements pris par ji
lors de l'acquisition de la branche
énergie d'alstom et nous avons pu
constater les engagements et les actions
qui ont été prises par ji alstom entre
2015 et 2018
l'investissement de près d'un milliard
d'euros en france le recrutement de
trois mille personnes ce qui fait qu'au
31 décembre 2018 effectivement seulement
25 emplois étaient en plus par rapport
au moment de l'acquisition
après un point haut de 425 emplois en
2010 est dit n'a pas réussi à recruter
les 1000 emplois comme elle espérait le
faire les villes emploi en plus de la
valence actuel et cela s'explique très
bien car la transition énergétique un
impact majeur sur jei qui dépend à 50 %
des énergies fossiles
elle est actuellement entraîne de revoir
son modèle économique dans le monde
entier dans ces conditions nous ne
restons pas les pois les bras ballants
nous avons mis en place un fonds de
réindustrialisation abondé par ji à
hauteur de 50 millions d'euros qui sera
présidé par un expert industriel
associera les élus et examinera les
projets industriels que vous avez
mentionné car il ne suffit pas d'avoir
des bonnes idées encore faut-il les
mettre en oeuvre de manière
professionnelle et je suis désolé je
suis myope
deuxième élément nous sommes attentifs à
la réorganisation de gini et nous
saluons positivement le renforcement de
ji renouvelables qui pèse 40 mille
employés dans le monde et qui représente
16 milliards de dollars de chiffre
d'affaires soit cinq divisions dont
quatre ont leur siège en france
enfin belfort nous avons un lien
constant avec les dirigeants de jean
nous sommes prêts à accompagner les
développements des activités nouvelles
les aéronautique mais également les juno
jumeaux numérique pour les centrales à
gaz donc vous voyez nous accompagnerons
ji mais dans un avenir qui ne sera pas
fondée sur les énergies fossiles je vous
renverse